Hi, EmacsColf.
This is color your Emacs with ease.
I'm Rio de Salada, and today's agenda is start with a brief introduction.
I will be talking about colors quite a bit.
What colors do you like?
Color spaces and some packages such as color.el, ct.el.
I'll be touching on a theme called Hasselberg theme which I created before wrapping up the
talk.
So a quick introduction about the talk.
The slide is available as an org mode file at codeberg, and if you're looking at it from
org mode, you probably want to have rainbow mode turned on or the best viewing, and this
is the case with the presentation today.
I'm Rio de Salada, and I'm available at RYTSWD at usual places.
So what color do you like?
And you might be able to tell I like orange, and that's the color that I use often.
And Emacs gives me all the control I want, so naturally I wanted to make it aesthetically
pleasing to my taste, which meant that I would like to have a dark theme, subtle theme,
with orange as a main accent color, but not too orange, so not everything very orange,
maybe use another blue-ish color as another accent.
Know that this presentation is based on Hasselberg theme more than more than that later.
But when I started my Emacs journey, I didn't start with creating a new theme from Get
Go.
I started with a theme called Nova Theme.
I really liked it. I made a few tweaks around org mode and headings, so that they were a
bit more geared towards my liking, which was around orange being sprinkled, sprinkled across.
And I got to it very nice looking, and I really liked it.
But when I started a long coin task with it, I kind of realized one thing, that it was
very colorful and in the way distracting.
And it actually wasn't about Nova Theme's fault.
It was just many editors, including Emacs and VS Code and other editors and modern themes,
are filled with colors.
Let's have a look.
At the top left, you can see Nova Theme with a bit of a pale greenish background with a
few colors, so purple, pink, blue, green.
You can see some colors like that with Nova Theme, nice looking colors, but still colorful.
Models to be then de tinted, bottom left is also very nice looking modern theme, but quite
colorful.
The same can be said for EF themes, our addition top right and do one as another bottom right.
So that let me to think, how can I make my code editing and coding tasks not to distracting
and I can focus on writing code.
And that was something I could manage with og mode, where I just specifically basically
used orange shades and not too much more.
That's what you're seeing at the moment.
And wanted to do something similar with coding and any general code.
And that led me to the journey of creating my own theme.
But before going to the theme, I need to talk about color spaces.
So SRGB, standard RGB is probably something that many people are familiar with.
HSL is for hue saturation and lightness, LCH is for light luminance, light or lightness,
chroma and hue.
And those are the color spaces probably commonly used in various spaces, but when it comes
to perceptual uniformity, there is an important difference between the color spaces.
So human perception of the color is not very straightforward.
And we can see in the reference here, let's have a look.
At the top, you can see the shade coming from left green to the right blue.
And in the top image, you can see half of it, perhaps, is very similar green color.
And when it comes to blue, you can see more of the different color gradients coming into
play.
The bottom color space is based on the perceptual uniform color space, which gives us a bit more
evenly distributed color gradient, which will be something more suitable for deciding on
the theme set up on the color set up, where you can have various themes that are defined
for human perceptions.
So perceptual uniformity is important.
And for that, it is important to mention about CIE, or International Commission of Elimination
in English.
And they just created important color spaces called CIE XYZ, which was from 1931.
CIE Lab, LAB, and LUV Love, 1976, respectively.
And those are the color spaces used in various fields and industries, and still relevant.
And there is quite a bit that you can read up on.
I'm not a color expert, so I have some references here.
But the TLDR of all of that is, consider using LCH variants over RGB or HSL for better
perceptual uniformity.
And specifically CIE Lab-based LCH, which is often called Lab-LCH, or just LCH, CIE Love-based
LCH is called Love-LCH, and there is a new rather modern LCH set up called OK-LCH, which
is based on OK-LAB.
So those are the color spaces that are worth looking at when it comes to creating shades.
And how do you create shades?
Color.el and CT.el are great solutions.
You can create shades and different colors based on RGB and hex.
And you can see in the red example here, FF0000 is a bright red, and you can darken it
by providing less red values by like CC or 8/8, and you can see that the colors are slightly
darker than the FF0000, but what if you are working with the complex colors, such as
FBB151, this particular orange.
And that's where color.el, CT.el, Community Play, color.el is a built-in package in EMAX,
so you can use it by just requiring it, and color darken name, and providing the color
with hex value with 40% gives you a darker orange without doing too much of a color computation
by hand.
And this hex value is something that EMAX understands, and Rainbow Mode does as well.
And when it comes to CT.el, it's not a built-in solution, but it's more versatile, and it works
with various color spaces.
So you can see that CT edit HSL, likeness, decrease by 40%, I would give us a darker color
by 40%, and we can also use LCH variant, which can use the LCH color spaces for darkening
the color.
This results in slightly different colors for this particular orange, but if you are working
with the green or blue or some other colors, it might be worth looking at LCH variant
rather than other color spaces.
With that, let's have a look at Hasbroke theme.
This is a theme that I created personally, and the name is based on the Swiss Alps, and
with the following ideas in mind.
It focuses on setting up shades, and shades by that you can see how the top of the heading
here is a bright orange color.
And other orange colors, this heading, and this heading are based on the top orange color
and then giving some shade and illuminance adjustment, essentially.
It follows a pattern from web design and tailwind color shades, a great example that you can
find if you have a look.
It does not use CT.el as it aims to be fully dependency free, and does not consider color contrast
for accessibility.
This is because it's personal, and I don't have that particular need.
This is based on love LCH rather than lab LCH, and that's another reason why I didn't
use CT.el, and it is highly experimental.
But the code is available at codeberg and GitHub just for your reference.
So let's see Hasbroke theme in action.
So this is the theme that we were looking at for org mode as well, but for the code, in
this case, elisp.
And you can see that the color is mostly white and blue, with orange spring, to spring
quarter cross for string input, and you can see some pink showing up as well, but essentially
all the color setup is done by shades.
So most of it is based on white or neutral, and there will be lighter and darker variants
that can be set for the primary color of blue, and you can see the darker and brighter
colors being used, and with that shade setup, I only have to provide a few colors as the
base colors, and from there I can define the shades for the theme setup, which leads to
creating a more monotonic color setup, where this one is a very monotonic, very subtle
difference of white colors used for the base colors, and I don't have to make too many
changes to the color setup, I just have to provide the base colors that are different.
The same can be set for this very orange color theme, which is based on the base colors
of orange-like colors, and gives the shade of various different setup.
And this means that I can use Asliberg theme nature color palette, and that gives me more
of a green-based color, where all the base colors are set up with a green-ish color setup.
With that, I would like to wrap up with a few ideas, when adjusting themes and working
with colors, maybe consider using CIE lab, CIE lab, or OK lab-based color spaces that would
give you different shades, which are easier to work with for human perceptions.
Color.EL and Citi.EL can be a great tool for making shades and work with color spaces, and
Hasliberg theme is yet another theme highly personal and experimental, but could be an
inspiration for your theme journey.
With that, why not sprinkle your emacs with your favorite colors.
Thank you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]